مصنع الجعة التيبر في الضفة الغربية هو
مخزن فلسطيني ناجح ينتج
600000 لتر من السنين يتم شحنها محليًا
إلى إسرائيل وإلى 15 دولة من
المغرب إلى الولايات المتحدة.
من مصانع تخمير عائلة الكاري وعلى
مدار كل تلك السنوات الخمس والعشرين ، تفاوضت العائلة على
عقبات لا تعد ولا تحصى فقط للحصول
على مشروبها في السوق في الخارج ، إنه يوم عاصف
هنا في الضفة الغربية ، لكننا أردنا
أن نأتي إلى هنا لنريكم
خزانات المياه لأن شيئًا واحدًا أنت  لا يمكن صنع
البيرة بدون الماء ،
لطالما كانت المياه مشكلة كبيرة في الضفة الغربية ،
تتحكم إسرائيل في إمدادات المياه
بيرة تايبي مثل جميع الفلسطينيين يحصلون على
بدل
بمجرد نفاد هذا البدل ، هذا
ما تريده أكثر عليك دفع ثمن
صهريج لنقله  قم بشحنه في الوقت الحالي في
فصل الصيف ، حيث نشعر
بنقص المياه ، وهذا هو الوقت الذي تريد فيه
تخمير المزيد من الجعة ، وذلك عندما يكون لدينا
الماء يأتي مرة واحدة في الأسبوع بموجب نظام
التشغيل 1995  لاتفاق ، احتفظت إسرائيل
بالسيطرة النهائية على موارد المياه ،
لكن شركة Co حملت السلطة العسكرية الإسرائيلية
المسؤولة عن المدنيين في
الضفة الغربية تقول إن مصنع الجعة يقع في
منطقة خاضعة للسيطرة
الفلسطينية والسلطات الفلسطينية هي المسؤولة
في جوهرها عندما يتعلق الأمر بقضايا المياه
يلقي كلا الجانبين باللوم عليها.  والأخرى كانت آخر
محاولة لحل
النزاع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني
في البحرين قبل أسابيع قليلة ، كشف
صهر الرئيس الأمريكي جاريد كوشنر
عن خطة اقتصادية
للفلسطينيين انتقدها الكثيرون لإعادة
صياغة الأفكار القديمة التي كانت غامضة بشأن
التنفيذ والتطبيق.  إيقاف
الحلول السياسية لنداء MIDI في وقت لاحق
وتقول عائلتها إن الأحلام الاقتصادية لا طائل من ورائها
دون تسوية سياسية أولاً
نحتاج إلى حل المشكلة السياسية التي
نحتاجها للعودة إلى التفاوض وحل
المشكلات السياسية ثم التحدث
عن الحلول الاقتصادية والاقتصادية لذلك
عندما  سمعت تلك الخطة ، ما
رأيك في أنني تجاهلتها بدلاً من ذلك  من
الوعود الاستثمارية المتخلفة عن الباب ،
تقول مادي سخرية إن الكثير يمكن تحقيقه من
خلال تخفيف القيود الإسرائيلية المفروضة على ضرائب
القواعد واللوائح الروتينية التي تقول إن
الفلسطينيين هم أول
حاجز طريق ، وهو الحاجز الحرفي الذي يمثل نقطة التفتيش الإسرائيلية
بين الضفة الغربية
وإسرائيل إذا نظرتم  على الخريطة ،
سترى المسافة بين بلدتنا
مرتبطة بموانئ حيفا التي نستخدمها
للتصدير على الخريطة ، يبدو أنها
تستغرق ساعة ونصف بالسيارة في الواقع ،
يستغرق الأمر ثلاثة أيام إذا كان كل شيء
يتحرك بسلاسة وهو ما لم يحدث أبدًا
تقول شركة الجات الإسرائيلية إن هذه
الادعاءات لا تتفق مع الواقع المتمثل في أن
أوقات عبور نقاط التفتيش للسلع قد
انخفضت إلى 90 دقيقة في المتوسط وأنه من
لمقرر إجراء تحسينات أخرى ، ل
ن لا يوافق كاري على ذلك ، ولكن بالعودة إلى ال
بت ، ستستمر العائلة في تك
ين نموذج مصغر لأعمالهم ووزن أع
الهم.  العوائق الاقتصادية الأوسع التي تواجه
الاقتصاد الفلسطيني لن يتم التخلص من السلاحف التي
تنقذها عائلة الكاري دون أن يكون
هناك ذلك السياسي
الاستيطان شيء يبدو
بعيدًا الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى
على الرغم من أن نادين والد ميدوسا هو
المتفائل الأبدي يومًا ما سنكون أحرارًا
، وآمل في المستقبل ألا
يتبقى لنا شيء سوى الأمل الكبير مايكل
هولمز سي إن إن تايبيه في الضفة الغربية
[موسيقى]